on
oh
on s'aperçoit qu'on est comme tout le
monde on est assis dans un bateau qui
ont parié comme tout le monde quoi et on
avait juste des gens qui bougent pas
qu'ils nous aiment pas donc on a
beaucoup plus dur pour nous
et donc ça permet aussi une liberté
beaucoup plus libre qu'en fauteuil
roulant parce qu'en fait sur l'eau on
fait on va où il veut quoi
rémy s'entraînent ici chaque week-end
car pour l'instant le reste de la
semaine
le jeune homme est en rééducation dans
un hôpital militaire parisien il y a 6
mois il faisait encore partie des
prestigieux commandos parachutistes les
au cours d'un entraînement sa vie a
basculé
j'ai eu un souci avec mon parachute
marché principal si je schématise s'est
pas ouvert comme ils auraient dû et
parachute de secours non plus ce qui a
créé que les deux parachutes se sont
emmêlés et donc j'ai fait une chute
d'environ
c'est assez dur à dire mais on va dire
une dizaine de secondes
300 400 mètres avant une vitesse
approximative de 80 100 km clairement
j'ai j'ai tout perdu donc j'ai perdu mon
métier et ma passion parce que vétéran
en équipe de france espoirs de
parachutisme donc en fait c'était ma
passion au numéro un c'était
parachutisme et donc
je me suis dit il faut que je fasse
quelque chose avant d'intégrer l'armée
rémy pratiquer le kayak alors depuis son
accident il n'a plus qu'une obsession
participer aux prochains jeux
paralympiques
pour y parvenir il a demandé l'aide
d'agnès une ancienne athlètes
paraplégiques elle aussi aller à rio en
2016 c'est très court donc il n'a pas de
temps à perdre donc toutes les étapes
que j'ai pu ah qu'est
ce que j'ai pu franchir
avec du temps et ben faut que je fasse
partager pour qu'ils gagnent qui les
passe temps à perdre et qu'ils puissent
avoir des chances à léry et ce qu'il
manque aussi à rémy c'est un kayak de
haut niveau adapté à son handicap
un investissement lourd alors sa
compagne vanessa a placé une urne dans
la boulangerie où elle travaille le
couple a déjà récolté près de 600 euros
là en disant qu'il veut faire les jo à
rio je sais qu'il ira et peu importe
après qu'il arrive premier au 10e ou
derniers temps qu'il y participe je sais
qu'il y participera ça yaya aucun doute
y fera tout pour y arriver touché par
l'histoire du jeune homme le patron de
vanessa a même décidé de le sponsoriser
c'est quand même un drame
notre logique et il fallait trouver une
bois ou si justement dans cette voie où
il est positif pour essayer de faire
quelque chose et ça faut l'encourager
c'est pour ça que je fuis après à
l'aider
rémy espère avoir son nouveau kayak au
mois de juin pour les championnats de
france une étape décisive pour espérer
se qualifier pour riom